Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and this week
for my bonus video I wanted to go a little
deeper into the faith of the seven.
So this will be about the Faith Militant.
Mostly a history video but after I’ll explain
how I think the show might introduce them
if they decide to use them.
Not all the major organizations and mercenary
groups have been featured from the books.
But Jonathan Pryce was cast as the High Sparrow,
the leader of the Church in King’s Landing.
So presumably we’ll get a look at the inner
workings of the church in and around baelor’s
sept.
If you’re just finding me for the first
time I’m doing weekly bonus videos till
season 5 gets here.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
I’m even doing a weekly book giveaway I’ll
explain at the end of the video.
The Faith Militant are the militarized arm
of the Faith of the Seven, they’re made
up from two different subgroups inside the
church called the Warrior’s Sons and the
Poor Fellows.
You can imagine how they decide who gets to
be what.
The Warrior’s Sons are made up of Knights
and other high born people that have sworn
off their lands and titles.
The swear their allegiance to the High Sparrow.
They get special armor just like the King’s
Guard.
And like the King’s Guard the most defining
characteristic of it is the cloak.
The Warrior’s Sons wear Rainbow colored
cloaks just like the King’s Guard wear White
Cloaks and the City Watch wear Gold Cloaks.
Their armor is silver and their swords have
a star shaped crystals in the pommels.
Stars as imagery of the seven pointed star
of the faith.
They have a reputation for fanaticism like
you might see in the unsullied, with the big
difference that they all are uncut.
Something about religious armies attracting
fanatics.
That can’t be good.
The Poor Fellows are made up of the peasantry.
But they allow women in their ranks.
They serve as lightly armored footmen and
instead of the really nice armor and weapons
that the warriors son’s get.
They just fight with whatever they can find.
They don’t have an official weapon and they
don’t wear the rainbow cloaks.
The military branches of the church have only
existed for certain periods in history but
they do predate Aegon’s Conquest.
Even though the High Sparrow is like a Pope
of sorts, I don’t really think of the Warrior’s
Sons as the Swiss Guard.
Those are the armed forces that protect the
real life Pope in Vatican City.
The Faith Militant are a fully mobilized army
that at times have enforced the will of the
acting High Sparrow.
There was even a conflict called the Faith
Militant Uprising after Aegon the Conqueror’s
Death.
Because Aegon had openly married his two sisters
the Faith of The Seven viewed their children
as sinful abominations, so when Aegon’s
oldest son Aenys took the throne.
The Faith launched an uprising to remove the
Targaryen’s from power.
Aenys was described as a very weak king so
his half brother Maegor, the son of Aegon’s
other sister and acting hand of the king,
launched the crown’s campaign to eliminate
the faith militant.
The uprising lasted all the way through Aenys
reign and Maegor who succeeded him instead
of Aenys son Jaehaerys the first.
This was Maegor the First also known as Maegor
the cruel.
He was the polar opposite of his brother Aenys.
As a way to turn the populace against the
Faith Militant, he placed a price on each
of their heads.
One Golden Dragon for the scalp of any Warrior’s
Son, remember they were the highborn knights
of the order and a Silver Stag for the scalp
of any Poor Fellow.
That act was what earned him the nickname
Maegor the Cruel.
His reign was really interesting so we can
talk more about it when the new World of Ice
and Fire book comes out in October.
It has complete family tree’s for the Targaryen’s
and the Starks.
He died under very mysterious circumstances
while sitting on the Iron Throne.
He literally died while just sitting on the
throne.
His reign only lasted for about 6 years.
Both he and his brother Aenys died when they
were about Cersei and Jaime’s age.
About mid 30s.
After Maegor died, Aenys son took the throne
at the age of 14 and immediately offered Amnesty
to the Faith of the Seven if they agreed to
disband the two orders of the Faith Militant.
The acting High Sparrow agreed and the conflict
was ended.
Fun Fact, one of Maegor’s wives was named
Jeyne Westerling, in the books, Jeyne Westerling
is also the name of the woman Robb Stark marries.
On the show they replaced that character with
Talisa Maegyr played by Oona Chaplin.
So you can see how they change things on the
show but try to work in references to the
books.
Westerling to Maegyr, which sounds a lot like
Maegor.
Anyone who’s worried about George RR Martin
expanding A Song Of Ice and Fire to 8 books
instead of just 7, remember that it gives
him more room for flashbacks to things like
this.
Although he is also planning a novel series
told from the perspective of the Targaryen
Family after A Song of Ice and Fire is over.
Thus far the show hasn’t really done flashbacks
like in the books, usually historical events
just get referenced in conversation.
The High Sparrow controls the Faith Militant
and currently where we are on the show, they’ve
still been disbanded.
The High Sparrow that Jonathan Pryce is playing
is the new one in Book 4.
During Season 2 the previous High Septon was
ripped apart when the Mob attacked Joffrey
in the streets.
They ripped his arm off on the show.
After that happened Tyrion appointed the new
High Sparrow.
That one was also eventually killed before
the one Jonathan Pryce is playing comes into
the story.
We saw Tyrion’s High Septon perform his
wedding to Sansa and Joffrey and Margeary’s
wedding ceremony.
In the timeline, he would have become High
Sparrow some time before the Battle of Blackwater.
The shows already changed a lot, so it’s
unclear how they’re going to deal with the
transition from High Septon number 2 to High
Septon number 3.
After Tyrion’s High Septon is killed mysteriously,
the faith itself chooses the next High Septon,
that’s the character Jonathan Pryce is playing.
The reason he’s nicknamed the High Sparrow
is because he’s chosen from amongst a group
of the poorest members of the faith that enter
king’s landing pleading for protection during
the war of the five kings.
They collectively take the name Sparrows,
so they’re referred to as The Sparrows,
thus the new High Septon is called High Sparrow.
There was a lot of shit going down in that
finale.
So it’s possible season 5 could pick up
and Jonathan Pryce will already be the High
Septon.
The show has a history of just brushing over
minor characters and the previous high septon
the one that did all the weddings, wasn’t
really featured that much.
Even though the show is changing a lot of
things Jonathan Pryce’s character will probably
have a lot of the broad strokes of the High
Sparrow from Book 4.
Because septon’s give up their name when
they’re appointed High Septon, no one knows
his true identity.
I know there are a lot of rumors and theories
about the High Sparrow being a very unlikely
character in disguise but if you have read
the books and want to talk about specific
things, just use spoiler tags in the comments.
Season 5 on the show is really the beginning
of uncharted territory in terms of book story.
So once we get to season 6 it will be a lot
easier for any of you that only watch the
show to avoid spoilers.
Even though there are rumors of a November
December Winds of Winter release date.
I think the casting of Jonathan Pryce specifically
is really interesting.
When I think of him I still think Bond Villain,
which is kind of awesome.
A bond villain is the leader of the faith
of the seven.
Just think about that for a minute and what
it might mean for season 5.
Let’s just forget about that GI Joe sequel
he was in recently.
Yikes.
There are some really amazing locations specific
to the Faith of the Seven that I’m really
looking forward to seeing.
We’ve already been in Baelor’s Sept for
Joffrey’s Wedding and Funeral, they really
went all out when they built that set for
season 4.
The High Sparrow is described as being unencumbered
by a lot of the pomp and ceremony that you
would think the leader of a church would have.
So he doesn’t wear crazy fancy robes or
the famous crown of the High Septon.
I’m always interested in the way the show
chooses to introduce characters, I still think
Oberyn Martell’s was one of the best Season
4 introductions.
The High Sparrow is a big character, but he’s
very different from Oberyn, so I would assume
they’ll give him an appropriately pious
entrance.
I think once season 5 actually starts we can
spend some time during my episode videos or
maybe just the bonus videos talking about
all the changes from the books.
I don’t want to do that quite yet since
I know a lot of you are still planning on
reading the books.
What I would like to suggest as just a fun
thing, is that we all re-watch some old episodes
together and just do like a twitter hashtag
so we can talk to each other while it’s
happening.
It’s a lot easier to do old episodes in
big groups of people because sometimes new
episodes air at different times around the
world.
So let me know if you guys would be interested
in something like that and we can pick a day
and time that works for everyone.
For example, everyone would find a copy of
the same episode to watch together and we
all just start watching at the same time and
live tweet the episode and then I’d make
a video with everyone’s most epic comments.
I’ll still be doing regular bonus videos,
I just thought that might be a fun thing to
do as a group.
For those that don’t know all my social
links are at the top of my channel page or
on the ‘about’ page.
I am working on a special video that will
explain which shows and movie videos I’m
doing this fall.
There’s some big stuff like Gotham and Agents
of SHIELD coming in september and everything
else comes back in october.
Be sure to subscribe to get that.
I’ll try to post it this week.
And feel free to suggest tv shows if there’s
something you really want to talk about but
I’m not doing right now.
There won’t be a Q&A for this tonight just
because of the Teen Wolf Finale and because
I need to buy furniture for my new place.
So i’ll just answer questions in the comments
like normal.
Right now learn more about the religions on
game of thrones by clicking here and click
here to learn more about the faceless men
in Braavos.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tonight.
High Fives!